Angela Merkel herzlich willkommen ja
herzlich willkommen Frau Schausten ich
freue mich hier zu sein Frau Merkel
Wolfgang Schäuble war in drei Kabinetten
ihr Minister Innenminister später
Finanzminister was ist das was für sie
bleibt von Wolfgang Schäuble diesem
besonderen politischen Leben für mich
bleibt dass er ein glühender Verfechter
der deutschen Einheit war ich bin ihm
zum ersten Mal begegnet als
stellvertretende Regierungssprecherin
als er den Einigungsvertrag verhandelt
hat zusammen mit gün
für mich bleibt diese wirklich
historische Rede als alle sich in
kleinremmerei über Bonn und Berlin
unterhalten haben über Stellenbesetzung
als er gesagt hat Leute wisst ihr was
hier passiert ist und wer wird in
Warschau an bon denken wenn er an die
deutsche Einheit denkt jeder denkt an
die gefallene Mauer das war unglaublich
bewegend und dann war er in den
Kabinetten den er angehörte einfach ein
Anker von Stabilität von Ruhe und
intellektuell im Scharfsinn also wenn
man intellektuell nicht gut drauf war
sollte man ihm besser nicht begegnen es
hat er ein dann auch ein bisschen spüren
lassen und damit ein bestimmtes Niveau
der politischen Debatte auch
durchgesetzt da war er streng das ist
richtig wie würden Sie rückblickend ihr
Verhältnis beschreiben ich glaube als er
mich zur
Generalsekretärin vorgeschlagen hat was
ja eine große Freude und Ehre war da
haben wir dann durchaus auch manchmal
unterschiedliche Akzente gesetzt und
19999 war dann der Europawahlkampf unser
erster gemeinsamer bundesweiter
Wahlkampf und da haben wir ein Plakat
gehabt wir beide wir gucken in
unterschiedliche Richtungen und da steht
nicht immer einer Meinung aber immer
gemeinsam ein gemeinsamer Weg und diese
Sache beschreibt es glaube ich am
allerbesten er hatte Sinn für Humor für
Ironie wir haben uns manchmal auch ein
bisschen gekappelt aber es war für mich
immer intellektuell Bereicherern mm
sie sagen es er hat sie zur
Generalsekretärin gemacht als er CDU
Vorsitzender war 2000 dann als er im
Grunde nach im Strudel auch der CDU
Spendenaffäre zurücktreten musste waren
sie seine Nachfolgerin standen stand
diese Entwicklung ein bisschen zwischen
ihnen auch weil sie haben das ja damals
auch ohne Information an ihnen gemacht
damals der berühmte Artikel in der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung wo sie
im Grunde die CDU altforderen ein
bisschen zur Seite geschoben haben das
war das was Wolfgang schäubel auch
gekennzeichnet hat das war natürlich für
uns alle keine einfache Zeit ich habe
das nicht vorausgesehen er hat das nicht
vorausgesehen und trotzdem sind ist hat
jeder sich dann wieder für die Politik
für das Land für die gemeinsame Sache
eingesetzt und trotzdem konnten wir gut
zusammenarbeiten und das geht nicht mit
jedem und das hat ihnen wirklich auch
charakterisiert dass er nach vorne
geschaut hat dass er geguckt hat dass er
sein politisches Leben wieder in die
Hand genommen hat und wirklich noch mal
großartiges daraus gemacht hat und sie
haben ihn eingebunden als Minister dann
auch in der Tat sie haben in der
gemeinsamen Zeit durchaus Krisen ja
erlebt die Finanzkrise nach 2010 später
die flüchtlingskrise wenn wir mal auf
die Finanzkrise einmal schauen da waren
war vor allem schuble ja der
Zuchtmeister hieß es damals für Europa
Griechenland
war da sehr kritisch die Südländer
sie wurden sehr angegangen scholuble und
Merkel man erinnert sich an die
Bilder war das alles richtig dieser Kurs
im Nachhinein würden Sie sagen dass war
der der richtige auch dieser harte Kurs
in Sachen Europa der richtige ich glaube
schon als ich sag mal bei der
Finanzkrise da war ja die Sache noch die
dabei Innenminister bei der
Weltfinanzkrise da war er sehr dafür
große Konjunkturprogramme zu machen um
die Weltwirtschaft wieder nach vorne zu
bringen bei der Eurokrise war er der
Meinung und das habe ich auch geteilt
man muss die Dinge von Grund
auf wirklich wieder in Ordnung bringen
und natürlich war das hart aber einfach
da so über die Probleme hinwegzugehen
wäre auch nicht richtig gewesen wir
haben dann zum Schluss auch wieder einen
gemeinsamen Weg gefunden auch dass
Griechenland in der Eurozone bleibt ich
glaube das war politisch auch absolut
richtig und insofern wie gesagt er war
streng nicht nur gegen sich selbst
sondern auch gegen andere aber das hilft
ja dann manchmal auch die Zukunft besser
zu gestalten sie haben vorhin gesagt sie
war nicht immer einer Meinung da hat's
auch mal Streit gegeben wenn Sie heute
auf die CDU auf ihre Partei schauen
unter dem neuen Vorsitzenden Friedrich
Merz den Schäuble immer gefördert hat
auch immer unterstützt hat anders als
als
sie ist das Erbe von Wolfgang Schäuble
heute stärker in der CDU als das von
Angela
Merkel das müssen andere wirklich
bewerten ich glaube wir haben beide
unsere Beiträge geleistet und schauen
Sie auch bei Friedrich märz ist ist ja
nicht so ich habe seine Wirtschafts
finanzpolitische Sachverstand den habe
ich immer geschätzt wir hatten da auch
manchmal unterschiedliche Meinungen und
wir hatten manchmal auch eben Interesse
am gleichen an der gleichen Position das
kommt vor in der Politik bei Wolfgang
Schäuble war nicht unterschiedliche
Meinung immer Streit sondern es war
manchmal Disput er konnte zuhören er
konnte seine Meinung ändern und man hat
sich gegenseitig befruchtet und das fand
ich immer toll an Frau Merkel sie
arbeiten derzeit an ihren politischen
Memoiren die im Herbst erscheinen sollen
ist Wolfgang Schäuble Hauptperson oder
eine
Nebenfigur erstens verrate ich nichts
aus dem was ich jetzt schreibe zweitens
hat Wolfgang schäble immer eine wichtige
Rolle eingenommen in den Positionen die
er hatte aber ohne jetzt unbescheiden zu
sein die Hauptperson bin natürlich ich
weil ich meine Memoiren schreibe was
haben Sie von ihm
gelernt gut zuhören
nicht zu schnell aufgeben
intellektuell scharf und klar
debattieren und zum Schluss immer einen
Kompromiss finden